welcome to share your world i'm caroline
and i love to travel
while i'm not able to explore right now
i'm inviting
four other travel lovers from different
cultural backgrounds
to come together and share our worlds
with each other
in this episode we're sharing a few of
our favorite wedding traditions
every culture has its own ways of tying
the knot
here's one of my favorite wedding
traditions
i'm armenian and one of my favorite
armenian wedding traditions is
when the bride and groom are finally
married
when they go into their new home that
they're going to be living in
the groom's mother usually places a
bread called
lavash which is like traditional
armenian flatbread
over the newly wed shoulders and that's
kind of to bless them with
bread and food in the house and then uh
one other thing before they step into
their home
they have to step on and break plates
and that's kind of like to get the bad
luck out of the house before they step
in
in korea there's a tradition called the
payback ceremony
so pebok is when you get dressed in an
old
it's like a traditional hamburg casey so
what is
you called it a han book is that did i
pronounce it correctly
yeah so a hanbok is a traditional korean
costume that they used to wear like
in the palace dynasties back in the day
it's like silk layers it's very colorful
all the women have dresses there's like
several skirts that you wear underneath
and like a cute little jacket but it's
like
big sleeves that are red and white and
pink and gold
and then the guys have also similar book
pants with vests and like a hat
and it's just like different layers but
it's very silk and colorful
sounds beautiful wow yeah it does sound
beautiful
so my cousin john got married and he
wore blue
and then my aunt and uncle also wear
blue colored handbooks because they're
on the groom side
so they'll sit down on cushions and then
my aunt uncle the groom's parents
will throw chestnuts and they have like
a silk attachment to her hanbok and
they'll both hold
each side and they'll try to catch as
many chestnuts as possible
and however many chestnuts you catch
means how many children you'll have
how many does your cousin catch three
three
yeah and he's one of three so wow
so i actually recently got married
my traditional uh nigerian
specifically yoruba ceremony um
was in september last year the
traditional
wedding outfit for bride is typically
the ero and buba
traditionally it's kind of like a boxy
sleeved
u-necked uh top that's sewn in lace
or um asha okay it's the more fancy
fabric that
we typically use for special ceremonies
it's not
just for weddings but you know typically
like weddings
graduation and then the buba is a
skirt that's wrapped around you and
folded over
in more modern times like you're not
limited to it
being a top and a skirt that you wrap
and fold
like you know there's just a little bit
more style in it
and then you also wear a gillette that's
uh wrapped really beautifully like the
bride's skelet is typically wrapped
in a special way to like make her stand
out the planning was fun
it was it was like 350 people just for
scale
like wow yeah and that's not even like a
big nigerian wedding
like at home some people's weddings in
nigeria are like a thousand people
because because you know that many
people i don't either
but it's it's thought of as like i think
it it
it leans to like the notion of like it
takes a village so it's like
everyone has a community has built this
child up
it reminds me of like when ancient
armenian weddings would happen
it would take like seven days and seven
nights and everyone would just bring
like fruits and
whatever they can for the couple but it
was kind of like they were all involved
in this couple
they were all involved in the marriage
[Music]
i want to travel i want to have a big
wedding well not me
maybe yeah i want to go to a wedding
yeah i want to go to a wedding
so i actually have my friend's wedding
in london next year it was actually
postponed from this year
so i'm really excited to go what's nice
is because we've been able to travel
domestically this year i've used my
marion bomboy bondless card
and i'm able to accrue a ton of points
which i can actually use to redeem
hotel nights in the future for my
friend's wedding in london let's all
make a vow to keep looking forward to
future weddings and trips
and in the meantime we hope our video
inspires you to learn more about these
and other wedding traditions from around
the world
[Music]
you